[Musique]
marre des enfants
o
o et qu'y a t'il nounours je un tronc
qu'est ce que tu aimes ça sent le départ
je descend vite chez mes amis pour les
jeunes
où je ne me suis pas trompé ça sent le
départ
quand les chansons va demain c'est
parents viennent le chercher très tôt
demain matin mais je reviendrai je
voulais dit je n'ai pas pas aussi oui je
le ramène dans la forêt elle a besoin de
prendre un peu leur ait fana je crois
que tout est à faire sur trets et matous
pin elle y est elle est enfantin marmite
les violets je voulais leur j'obéirai
d'où
ma guitare je crois bien qu'il manque ma
guitare il n'y a pas de qui parle-t-on
talent à charge pour les gens je tête
nicolas
c'est que moi je ne pars pas sans ma
guitare
juillet tu as tu as un curieuse
euros
elle n'est pas là
oula tubize cornichons moi je l'avais
laissé sur la table je suis sur dix mois
je n'ai pas ce n'est pas 3 qui aurait
fait une blague à cornichons dit ne te
cache pas derrière les branches
regarde moi
[Musique]
abo j'ai compris
juliette a way ma guitare
merci
est les souris
auquel cottyn je vais la chercher à voir
elle me dit toujours la vérité
tiens voilà ta guitare merci nicolas
tu es mon ami
je suis bien content d'avoir retrouvé
jeunes la musique
oui pendant que vous vous couchez
[Musique]
ou
n'est pas
[Musique]
oh
trop cette coquine de juliette à avait
caché la guitare de cornichons oh oh oh
oh et ça t'amuse
je te drôle on s'en va oui nounours en
route
bonne nuit les enfants
embrasser bien fort vos parents
et fait pour eux
[Musique]
oh
et